la mise en oeuvre de la réforme de
l'organisation territoriale de l'état
c'est l'objet de la circulaire du 12
juin envoyée par le premier ministre aux
préfets
elle rappelle notamment c'est à
l'échelon départemental que doivent être
mises en oeuvre les politiques de l'état
une directive rappelé par le préfet des
yvelines lors de son intervention devant
l'assemblée départementale le vendredi
28 juin et illustré avec l'exemple de la
loi sru sur le seuil de logements
sociaux imposé aux communes
notre interprétation sera toujours
positive partir du travail de terrain et
pour nous mobilisons tous les moyens
pour accompagner dans ce cadre
réglementaire en effet contraignant et
que notre vision des choses sera
toujours une vison bienveillante pour
une application la plus intelligentes et
imaginatives de la loi du côté des
institutions décentralisées conseillers
municipaux ou départementaux maires ou
présidents de départements les attentes
sur l'acte de décentralisation sont
importantes alors je pense qu'il faut
donner plus de pouvoir aux collectivités
tout ce que l'état ne fait pas bien à
l'échelon central il faut le confier aux
collectivités l'état lui doit mieux
faire ce qui est le coeur de son métier
c'est la défense c'est la sécurité
c'est la diplomatie bien entendu et qui
sont aussi les angles l'unité nationale
mais localement on n'est plus
opérationnel dont il ya les communes et
on soutient de ces communes
il y a les départements les départements
qui coordonne qui accompagne les
communes leur intercommunalité je dirais
de redonner à la proximité et redonner
aux territoires les compétences et
l'autorité et la responsabilité qu'ils
doivent avoir
qui mieux que les élus de territoire je
dirais sur la proximité sont à même de
mettre en place une réorganisation sur
la réorganisation des services de l'état
dans le département les directives sont
en cours d'application
le gouvernement lancera en 2020 la
réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales